[Music]
prince william and kate middleton's
first joint portrait is unveiled and
gotta say the royals are looking regal
check out the duke and duchess of
cambridge immortalized as art at the
university of cambridge's fitzwilliam
museum naturally william and kate wanted
to see themselves up close and personal
so they stopped by cambridgeshire on
thursday to check it out in person and
it's the details in every stroke that
really wow us british artist jamie
korres painted the image kate posing in
an emerald silk gown with statement
sleeves and matching manolo pumps
per usual serving us high fashion and
sophisticated glamour
next to kate prince william in a classic
suit with a teal tie complimenting his
wife's dress
we think this side by side of the pair
smirking with an off guard look really
captures their true essence as future
king and queen
and that's exactly what the artist says
he wanted to embody in a statement korth
explains he wanted to show the duke and
duchess in a manner where they appeared
quote both relaxed and approachable as
well as elegant and dignified
william and kate's first official joint
portrait comes just days after a big
milestone for the duke who rang in his
40th birthday on june 21st to celebrate
the palace posted a series of sweet
picks of william throughout the decades
e.t learned the royal family will likely
keep the festivities pretty chill they
were understandably being very
tight-lipped about birthday plans this
is going to be a private secret but i
wouldn't be at all surprised if the
cambridge is through something of a
joint party probably pretty low-key they
do like to keep below the radar they
tend not to want to do things that
perhaps seen as overly flashy or overly
showy
sounds about right the royals have
always focused on their philanthropy and
for william it all started with his late
mom princess diana
homelessness has always stuck with me as
a topic and as an issue i want to fight
for the royal paid tribute to her in the
days leading up to his milestone
birthday by hitting the streets to sell
copies of the big issue magazine a
publication put out by people working to
end homelessness william explains he
first visited a homeless shelter when he
was 11 alongside his mom and now he
feels inspired to carry on her legacy by
giving back
[Music]
you